[音楽]
[拍手]
私は大学生になるまで一般家庭で生ゴミが
捨てられるのが普通だということを知り
ませんでし
たなぜなら私の家では生ごみは退避にする
のが普通だったからです
私はこのことをそれまで違和感を持つこと
は特にありませんでし
た60年前私の祖母は結婚と同時に家を
立て節約のために自分で野菜作りをしよう
と痩せた土地を耕し始めまし
たその時に自分で退避作りを始めまし
た30年前私の母は病気になった祖父の食
幼女をきっかけに職の大切さに気づき
土作りにたどり着きまし
た私は2人の背中を見て育ちました2人は
生ゴミを資源として大切に取り扱ってい
まし
た在学中フィリピンに必殺に機会があり
ました
そこで私が当たりにしたのは安価な
ジャンクフードやお菓子でお腹を満たす
子供たちの
姿それを見て驚いた私は現地のNGO担当
者に尋ねまし
たそこで特に貧困世帯の子供では職を選ぶ
選択肢が狭まっていること他の選択肢が
あったとしてもそれを知る機会がないこと
そういった食べ物を食べ続けることによっ
て味覚がおかしくなってしまって味が濃い
ものしか美味しいと感じられなくなって
しまっているという実態を知りまし
たこの子たちはこういった食べ物を食べ
続けたら一体どうなってしまうん
だろうこういった現状を目の前にしても私
にはどうすることもでき
ないそういった気持ちが降りかかってき
まし
た
一方でそこでは新鮮なお野菜を手にする人
たちの姿もありまし
た帰国
後日本でも同じような状況があることを
知り
ます帰国して自分の住んでる環境を見直し
てみまし
た私の家は決して裕福ではありませんでし
たがいつもおいしくて新鮮お野菜が身近に
ありまし
た小さい時は祖母の畑に母や妹と一緒に
行ってお手伝いをし
たり大学生になってからは反応大学生とし
て自分で野菜作りをするようにもなりまし
た自分で作ってみると野菜作りの大変さや
楽しさを実感することができ
ます地域では生ごみ避を使って農がお野菜
を育ててくれ
ますその農家さんが育ててくれたお野菜は
地域のクリーニング屋さんの前であったり
パン屋さんの中であったり私たちの暮らし
の中に身近なところに並んでいますしかも
それも手に取りやすい価格で並んでいるん
ですこの地域では生ゴミが地域の中で野菜
に変わってそれが食卓に登ってい
ますその環境改めて見直して私はこれほど
なく安心感を覚えまし
たそしてこの活動に価値を改めて気づかさ
れたん
です誰もが安心できる職を手に入れられる
環境を作っていきたいこれが私がこの活動
を始めたきっかけ
ですかつて日本が世界一の循環型社会と
言われていた
時代神や衣類や糞尿などあらゆるものが
地域の中で社会の中で循環していまし
た生ゴミも
また家畜の餌であったり退避であった
りっていうところで活用されていまし
た高度経済成長機
行私たちのライフスタイルの変化とともに
これまで引き継がれてきた大悲づりの知恵
や技術が失われ始めてい
ます私たちの暮らしと土が分断した
結果生産しなくなったたくさんの人々の
胃袋を満たすために大量生産を記述とした
農業が主流となっていきまし
たその結果私たちの命を支える土が土上が
急速に劣化してい
ます一方
で生ゴミは有機物の中でも特に栄養化の
高い資源
です退避には土上を改善して地球温暖化を
緩和させる効果があり
ます
現在日本では日本の家庭では
90%以上の生ゴミが捨てられてしまって
い
ますその量約750万
T生ゴミは8割以上水分
ですその水分を燃やすということは木に水
をかけているのと同じです燃やすために
たくさんのエネルギーとお金を必要とし
ますそして何より生ゴミを燃やすと栄養と
して戻ってくることはありませ
ん国連の調査による
と世界の約7割が2025年までに都部に
住むようになると言われていますという
こと
は生ゴミが都部ででさらに出てくるという
です逆に考えてみる
と生ゴミを都部で資源として循環させる
ことができれ
ば持続可能な食料システムを加速させる
ことができるかもしれないということ
です私たちに身近な生ゴミを捨てて遠く
から肥料を持ってきてるこの仕組みなんだ
か変だと思いません
か
クラシと土をつぐツールこれがコンポスト
です都会の人でも楽しくおしゃれに快適
にできるコンポストこれがバック型の
コンポスト
ですおしゃれですよ
ねこのコンポストには約400gの生ゴミ
が毎日入れることができ
ます1年で100kmから150kmの
生ゴミをあなたのベランダで栄養に変える
ことができるん
ですこのコンポストを開発して以降これ
までコンポストを始めなかった人々が参加
し始めてい
ます彼らはコンポストで美生物に出会い
考え方が
変わり循環型のライフスタイルへと転換し
始めてい
ます先日
あるコンポストユーザーさんがこんな話を
してくれまし
た子供と料理をしていた時のこと
です3歳の娘が料理で出た生ゴミを
お母さんとこに持ってきてこれコンポスト
に入れるんだよねて言ったん
ですこれまで野菜嫌いで全然野菜を食べ
なかった子供が一緒に育てた野菜を
パクパク食べるんです
よこの話を聞いて私は家庭でじわりと捨て
ない暮らし楽しい循環生活が育まれてる
ような感じがしてとっても嬉しくなりまし
た都部には自分で退避を使いきれない人も
当然い
ますそんな人でも循環生活に自分ごとして
参加してもらえるような仕組み作りを行っ
てい
ますこの写真は東京赤坂の循環拠点の様子
です
コンポストユーザーさん
はこの退避の入ったバッグをこの循環拠点
まで持ってき
ますそこで写真のように退避をバーっと
出しながら私たちコンポストアドバイザー
とコンポストの話であったりその人の子供
の話であったりいろんな話をしますで
私たちアドバイザーさんとそのユーザー
さんとの会話だけではなくユーザーさん
同士でもいろんなお話をされてい
ますさらにその横で
は生ごみ退避で育った野菜で作野菜を作っ
て農家さんが販売をしています地域住民の
傾けであったりユーザーさんであったり
そこでもいろんな会話が生まれています
このお野菜どこで作ってるんですか
こないだ買ったお野菜すごくおいしかった
ですそんな会話がされてるんですねさらに
その後ではレストランでその農家さんが
作ったお野菜
が料理となって提供されてい
ますこの農家さんと私たちとレストランと
3者で協力することによって都市部におけ
る栄養循環を実現可能なものとしまし
た今後はコミュニティガーデンを点とした
循環モデルも作っていきたと考えてい
ますコミュニティガーデンは大作りや野菜
作りをするだけでなく子供たちに向けて脳
の教育であったり環境教育食育であったり
いろんなプログラムを実施することができ
ますさらにこの農園の端っこの方では地域
住民が自ら畑を耕したり地域住民に開かれ
たイベントを実施したりいろんな機能を
持った循環拠点になり
ます将来この子供たちが大きくなった
時生ゴミを捨てない暮らしが当たり前の
社会があるよう
に将来誰もが安心できる野菜を手にできる
環境があるように私は小さな循環をこれ
から日本中に広げていきたいと思い
ます今日あが出す生ゴミをゴミ箱に捨てる
のかそれともコンポストで栄養に変えるの
かあなたの選択があなたの未来を変えます
ありがとうございまし
た